[Música]
ah
es tal vez la norma más importante de su
tipo en los últimos 30 años así la
calificó el presidente de estados unidos
joe biden cuando firmó esa histórica ley
sobre el control de armas de fuego con
la que según dijo se van a salvar vidas
este proyecto de ley bipartidista para
frenar la violencia armada en eeuu fue
aprobada ya por el congreso se trata de
la respuesta más amplia dada por el
legislativo de ese país en décadas a las
masacres recientes que han consternado
no solamente a eeuu sino también al
mundo entero sólo para recordar algunas
de ellas o las más recientes la muerte
de 19 menores de edad y dos maestras en
una escuela primaria en la localidad de
oval de en el estado de texas pocos días
antes un hombre asesinó a diez personas
afrodescendientes en un supermercado en
la ciudad de buffalo en el estado de
nueva york el texto tiene como objetivo
fortalecer la verificación de
antecedentes penales y también
psicológicos de quienes compran armas en
edades comprendidas entre los 18 y los
21 años así buscan entonces controlar
y legal de armas y también intentan
mejorar el financiamiento de programas
que van a estar dedicados a la salud
mental veamos más detalles en el
siguiente reporte que preparó la
redacción de france 24 para ustedes
un día monumental en la lucha contra la
violencia armada eso dijo yo vayan tras
firmar una ley bipartidista que parecía
inimaginable hasta la reciente serie de
tiroteos masivos en el país el último de
ellos la masacre de 19 estudiantes dos
profesoras en una escuela primaria de
igual de texas el 24 de mayo ward se
salvarán vidas a nuestro regreso de
europa
hill y yo organizaremos un acto en la
casa blanca el 11 de julio para celebrar
este logro histórico con los miembros
que votaron por estas familias y las
familias que de hecho fueron víctimas de
los tiroteos que hemos visto vivir si el
texto es el acto más impactante sobre la
violencia con armas de fuego producido
por el congreso desde 1993 sin embargo
están lejos de lo que quería
originalmente bailan o incluye por
ejemplo la prohibición de las armas de
asalto lo que se incluye es un refuerzo
a la comprobación de antecedentes
penales y psicológicos de los
compradores de armas de entre 18 y 21
años bloqueara también la venta de armas
a los condenados por maltrato a sus
parejas aunque no estén legalmente
casados
a los estados a poner en marcha leyes de
banderas rojas que faciliten a las
autoridades la retirada de armas a
personas consideradas peligrosas
irónicamente la firma del proyecto de
ley llega pocos días después de que el
tribunal supremo falló en contra una ley
del estado de nueva york que prohibía
llevar armas de fuego en público
si bien esta ley no abarca todo lo que
quiero si incluye medidas que he pedido
durante mucho tiempo y que salvarán
vidas eso fue lo que dijo el mandatario
estadounidense a través de su cuenta en
twitter tras ser aprobada esta ley
quedan también habilitados 13 mil
millones de dólares para los diferentes
programas enfocados en prevención y
verificación también salud mental y
también para destinar dinero para los
diferentes programas locales que tienen
los diferentes estados de la unión
americana es esto suficiente es entonces
la prevención y la verificación la forma
de evitar más tiroteos en ese país y
también nos queda otra pregunta sobre la
mesa para este debate cómo está la salud
mental de los ciudadanos de eeuu para
seguirles dejando la enorme
responsabilidad de tener armas en su
posesión de una manera tan fácil como es
actualmente adquirirlas en ese país
estas y otras preguntas pues las vamos a
analizar en este programa y para eso
hemos invitado a maribel balbín es ya
representante de la organización prevent
and violence en el estado de florida en
el sur de eeuu ella se conecta desde la
ciudad de miami
desde la ciudad de mexico a través de
colecciones telefónicas está con
nosotros maría elena morera ella es
analista de seguridad justicia y control
de armas ella también es presidenta de
la organización causa en común que es
una ong que lucha por los derechos
humanos y las libertades civiles ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de esta conversación estamos a
través de las diferentes redes sociales
ustedes ya lo saben estamos en facebook
en instagram en twitter y pueden ver
también nuestra señal en streaming a
través de youtube nos encuentran como
france24
bajo ese anti logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales comienzo entonces con mi
primera invitada con maribel balbín en
la ciudad de miami agradeciéndole que
esté con nosotros en el programa gracias
por acompañarnos maribel y el punto de
partida para esta discusión este
proyecto de ley bipartidista que eso
dice mucho sobre la importancia de este
tema para el congreso de eeuu para
frenar la violencia armada en parecía
que era completamente inconcebible que
fuera a darse este tipo de
modificaciones que llegaron al congreso
y que fueron aprobadas se ha logrado qué
significa esto para eeuu
definitivamente un paso gigantesco como
tú has presentado en el reporte y
también todo depende de quien lo vea
porque seguimos un grupo que lo está
viendo como que el vaso está medio lleno
y otro grupo que lo ve como que el vaso
está medio vacío obviamente se quería
mucho más las personas que están
trabajando por tener este tipo de leyes
y por años y años y años hubieran
querido que hubiera mucho más pero si se
está en primeros es algo no es algo con
que comenzar y muy importante es lo de
los antecedentes porque muchos muchas
personas pueden tener armas en este país
sin tener ningún tipo de antecedentes
chequeado sin tener nada porque hay
muchas formas de obtener esa arma no por
lo tanto esta lista de
y la legislación lo que incluye
realización nos va a dar un comienzo
para poder llegar a y leyes que en
realidad hagan mucho más efecto en un
futuro la opinión de maribel balbín
desde la ciudad de miami ahora a través
de línea telefónica nos conectamos con
maria elena morera en la ciudad de
méxico gracias maría elena por estar con
nosotros también en el programa y
también punto de partida la misma
pregunta parecía completamente imposible
llegar a un acuerdo también entre
republicanos y demócratas para hacer
este tipo de modificaciones estas
propuestas de tipo bipartidista dice
mucho de lo que está sucediendo allí en
eeuu como se puede recibir esta
modificación a la ley y estas
sugerencias que había hecho también el
presidente yo vaivén en su momento y
diferentes sectores de la política
estadounidense
y me parece importantísimo lo que logró
el presidente de byd en que si bien pues
todavía que hiciéramos mucho más porque
como mexicanos no solamente por lo que
están sufriendo las personas en eeuu
sino porque lo que también sufrimos
nosotros en méxico por las armas de
asalto por si hubiéramos querido que
llegar hasta este punto de no permitir
las armas de asalto sin embargo bueno
fue un adelanto importante lo que logró
el presidente vaivén en este sentido y
como ya decía maribel y sobre todo la
prevención en el tráfico de armas y
mejorar la regulación en materia de
almacenamiento y por supuesto la edad
restringida para el chilín cierto tipo
de armas
me parecen sus portantes y también me
parece muy importante en términos de
prevención y lo que ahí se determinó no
y el presupuesto que ya mencionan
ustedes criterios
maría elena morera desde ciudad de
mexico ago la ronda entonces comienzo
con maribel en la ciudad de miami
mientras hacemos ajustes con el audio de
maría elena en ciudad de méxico para
tenerla conectada por skype también
veíamos en la descripción de los
diferentes puntos que hay en esta ley
aprobada que está enfocada básicamente
en la prevención y en la verificación
desde su punto de vista maribel es esto
suficiente por lo menos para la
coyuntura actual como o tal vez es un
buen punto de partida como lo ve usted
es un buen punto de partida
lo importante es que ver como cada
estado entonces aplica estas leyes para
tener un poco más de uniformidad porque
el problema que existe acá es que cada
estado puede tener sus propias leyes
aquí por lo menos tenemos entonces una
guía donde hay ciertas cosas que todos
los estados tienen que tener por lo
tanto definitivamente un paso hacia
adelante
específicamente se hizo mucho hincapié
en el hecho de lo que se habla de
abordar un vacío que existía en lo que
era las personas que no están casadas
pero son víctima de violencia doméstica
estas personas podrían tener armas y no
había una relación formal esto va a
tomar ya y hacer un efecto bastante
importante porque se ha comprobado que
sucede mucho donde a un novio pues luego
regresa cuando una relación se termina
por lo tanto que eso fue un punto muy
importante que muchos de los
legisladores querían incluir
definitivamente en lo que le llama la
bandera roja hemos comprobado que por
ejemplo aquí en la florida que está en
efectos de tiempo eso el resultado ha
habido personas que se han identificado
antes de que llegara a cometer un crimen
mayor porque se le identificó a través
de este tipo de legislación por lo tanto
sí por lo menos unas cuantas cosas muy
importantes pero definitivamente lo que
es el gran punto que es lo de los rifles
de asalto que es cómo eliminarlos eso
todavía no se puede tocar porque no hay
forma que los republicanos lo consideren
si no estoy mal eso se llama la laguna
del novio esa parte de la legislación
que usted mencionaba en cuanto a las
personas que padecen violencia doméstica
o termina una relación y tienen
problemas con su expareja y hay
posibilidades de desarrollar allí en ese
conflicto algunos hechos de violencia
mariaelena su opinión sobre esto este
mecanismo de prevención y verificación
es un buen punto de partida ya maribel
decía que para ella lo es usted cree que
es simplemente una legislación que
modifica no es un buen punto de partida
como lo ve usted
no yo creo que sí es un punto de partida
bueno definitivamente pues todos los
adelantos siempre son buenos y sobre
todo hablando del tema de armas en eeuu
que ha sido un tema muy complejo muy
debatido y donde ayude pues un gran
poder económico y político puesto a
favor de que no haya regulaciones al
respecto entonces yo creo que es un buen
punto de partido sin embargo sí creo que
tienen que llegar hasta evitar el que
puedan comprar rifles de asalto porque
por un lado me parece hasta de sentido
común nadie usa un rifle de asalto para
ir a cazar patos verdad entonces si
deberían estar estos restringidos y
sobre todo restringido porque hacen las
armadoras un mal uso un uso ilegal
permiten la venta a cualquier persona
pues en américa en américa no es latina
no hay en méxico lo estamos llenando de
las armas con las que ellos están
haciendo ricos a través de la sangre de
mexicanos y sudamericanos
maría elena llama a nivel mencionaba
esas diferencias que hay en cuanto a la
legislación entre los estados a que
estamos hablando de una normativa
federal pero puede volverse un traspié
para darle un poco de solución a este
problema de violencia en eeuu
precisamente esa disparidad en la
normativa entre los estados que no hay
una base digamos homogénea pareja entre
los 50 territorios entre los 50 estados
porque es que por ejemplo vemos estados
como maine minnesota y vermont alaska
en donde bajan un poco más el listón en
cuanto a la normativa y personas de 16
años con algún tipo de supervisión
pueden comprar un arma de fuego en estos
estados 16 años nada más eso puede
entorpecer que ésta esta modificación de
la ley pueda ser exitosa
si puede entorpecer lo ojalá el
presidente de bailén y sus aliados lo
eviten porque ya lo vimos el 23 de junio
también de este año la resolución de la
corte en el estado de nueva york no
justo que va en contra de lo que está
pidiendo vaivén en la nueva ley que
hicieron entonces precisamente y claro
que en un país democrático pues cada
estado puede determinar algunas de las
cosas pero sin embargo yo creo que sí
puede afectar no en el estado de nueva
york por ejemplo con una votación de
seis a favor y tres en contra se
determinó en constitucional la ley de
control de armas del estado de nueva
york donde era muy restrictiva en
algunos aspectos para que los ciudadanos
pudieran comprar armas por ejemplo se
requería que los ciudadanos demostrarán
que a través de un procedimiento ante
las autoridades locales que tenían una
necesidad particular lo que ellos le
llaman el pro por causa
y cargar armas en público no extendiendo
este derecho a posesión de armas en sus
domicilios entonces creo que por un lado
el presidente de bailén está empujando
que en un país democrático donde si
tienen
yo te podría decir comparado con los
países latinoamericanos
si tienen un estado de justicia potente
donde está mucho mejor regulada la vida
en eeuu
bueno pues realmente el uso de armas por
ejemplo de asalto pues no debería de ser
y además si debería de ser el uso de
estas armas primero para personas que
sepan usarlas no porque yo me imagino
estando en un tiroteo
como los que se han dado muchísimo en
este año en eeuu y aún teniendo un arma
la persona está capacitada para
utilizarla cuántas veces en el año ha
ido a prácticas de tiro y que tanto su
mente le puede responder a hacer un acto
de estos y no terminar en una tragedia
mayor donde termine matando a otras
personas
ya vamos a hablar de la salud mental
maría elena lo tengo aquí en la agenda
de temas para conversar y analizar
maribel regreso con usted le pregunto
por esa falta de una base homogénea y se
queda coja digamos esta ley que con
tanto entusiasmo ha aprobado el congreso
en eeuu el mismo presidente yo vaivén
dijo no es todo lo que yo quería pero
hay algunas cosas importantes que yo
llevaba
tratando de implementar desde hace mucho
tiempo por lo menos hay algunas de ellas
pero esto va a ser tal vez un traspié
como lo vio usted
sin definitivamente una gran victoria
porque si lo vemos como que fue voltec a
las décadas donde el congreso
simplemente no permitía la conversación
acerca de cómo regular las armas por lo
tanto si tenemos que aceptarlo como algo
muy bien venido en cuanto a lo que
sucede y específicamente como decía
grial en acerca de nueva york
una vez que
anteriormente pues no se podía decir si
no tenía una explicación bien
contundente de por qué tenía que tener
un arma contigo para poder llevarnos
ahora tienes que definir qué es lo que
es un área sensitiva para entonces poder
negar ese derecho que le acaba de dar la
corte suprema a las personas de nueva
york cada estado va a tener ahora que
definir qué es lo que es un área sea
intuitiva y entonces con la legislatura
que esté a favor de hacer semejante cosa
poner esas regulaciones para que la
persona no pueda llevar el arma no puede
aportar el arma en público en ciertos
lugares que nuevamente colgaron al
principio cada estado va a tener su
propio concepto de lo que es y no es un
área asertiva eso te complica mucho pero
si definitivamente tenemos dónde empezar
la conversación
maribel en ese orden de ideas y teniendo
claro que cada uno de los estados tiene
que tomar la decisión en cuanto a su
legislación sobre este tema
ya hemos mencionado algunos de los de
los estados que tiene unas normas
bastante particulares en eeuu
completamente polarizado en un año donde
hay elecciones a final de año elecciones
muy importantes de medio término este
tema que tanto puede llegar a
polarizarse ya es una gran controversia
dentro de la sociedad estadounidense y
dentro de el legislativo
de repente hay dos temas grandes para
las elecciones de noviembre como la
corte suprema los acaba de terminar como
tales no el portar armas base más
importante nuevamente en estado donde
han habido incidentes por ejemplo en
texas que sucedió esta primera tragedia
en la florida cuando ocurrió la horrible
tragedia de parkland se desarrollaron
una cantidad de leyes que son partes de
lo que se quiere aceptar adoptar mejor
dicho alrededor de toda la nación pero
que no se puede mover sino de este
estado en estado va a ser una pregunta e
influencia que va a influenciar el voto
de noviembre absolutamente lo que es las
armas y ahora él ha vuelto van a hacer
dos preguntas quedan están muy muy en lo
presente para como las personas van a
votar en noviembre y dado el hecho de
que a los ciudadanos americanos tienen
ciertas en gran mayorías que piensan que
sí que hay que tener algún tipo de
manejo donde las armas se tienen que
manejar de una forma responsable y lo
mismo tiene que ver con la otra
si según encuestas hechas en diferentes
ciudades de eeuu cerca del 70% de los
ciudadanos está de acuerdo en que se
legisla para restringir la venta de
armas de asalto usadas en la mayoría de
estos tiroteos masivos que hemos visto
en diferentes ciudades de eeuu maría
elena no hay pedido o sea hay 70 por
ciento de la población que piensa que si
va a haber una modificación pero no hay
una solicitud formal por parte de la
sociedad de eeuu para decirle al
legislativo de ese país necesitamos una
modificación necesitamos una ley maya
más estricta y no solamente que venga
desde la iniciativa de los legisladores
así es fíjate que es curioso porque
cuando los ciudadanos están pensando en
un 70 por ciento que dice queremos que
haya más restricción al uso de armas lo
que debemos es que los legisladores pues
a muchos de ellos van en sentido
contrario por ejemplo el 34 por ciento
de los republicanos y el 87 por ciento
de los demócratas si consideran que debe
ser una una regulación más estricta sin
embargo en esto vemos que la mayoría de
los republicanos piensan que no no o por
ejemplo este el 66% de los republicanos
piensan y el 24 los demócratas que debe
ser necesario armar a maestros de
primaria y secundaria
entonces si nos vamos a lo que están
diciendo
los legisladores y lo que la población
está sintiendo pues pareciera que van en
otro sentido también hay que decirlo
eeuu está sumamente polarizado y este y
como decía maribel pues también el tema
del aborto serán dos temas para los para
las siguientes elecciones
donde esperamos que avancemos en
términos de los derechos de las personas
y no en contra de los derechos de las
personas y yo creo que el principal
derecho que en el tema de armas pues
precisamente es evitar el hacer daño a
los demás es evitar que una persona
pueda salir a la calle y disparar a
diestra y siniestra y quitarle la vida a
la gente no porque no tienen los
problemas que tenemos en mexico de
violencia sin embargo los problemas que
tienen de violencia por el mal uso de
las armas es enorme en eeuu solamente en
2022 vemos que en eeuu hay un total de
mil
357 personas heridas y 278 personas
muertas por estos tiroteos simplemente
en los pues en los cinco meses que van
del año
si son cifras alarmantes que dicen mucho
de la situación de violencia que se está
viviendo allí maribel en la ciudad de
miami a qué se debe esta falta de
sintonía entre este 70% de la población
que dice que hay necesidad de una
legislación más rigurosa y el
legislativo y también porque no hay
iniciativas ciudadanas
digamos convocar a un tipo de referendo
donde sean los mismos ciudadanos quienes
voten o exijan a los legisladores
queremos hacer un cambio la legislación
xxi muy importante no todos los años
especialmente en la organización que yo
representé por ejemplo vamos a la
legislatura y todos los años hay en
legislación que se propone normalmente
es para liberar el uso de las armas
porque porque la florida por ejemplo la
mayoría en los tres en lo que es el
congreso y lo que es la casa son
republicanos
el problema existe en el hecho de que la
distribución de que tiene que ver con la
persona electa y los votantes los mapas
que hacen esa distribución es bien
confundido y terminamos en una
representación que no en realidad
representa a la mayoría de las personas
sino que de la forma que está
distribuido terminamos de esa forma por
lo tanto las opiniones de las personas
electas no están necesariamente en
conexión con los votantes pero también
cuando hablas de unas iniciativas desde
de los votantes cada año lo hacen más
difícil en estos momentos es una cosa
casi imposible hacer una recogida de
firmas para poner algo en una boleta
para o una elección a través del estado
completo porque acaban en esta última
por ejemplo legislación todavía hacerlo
más difícil para los votantes por lo
tanto las iniciativas se han hecho más
difícil cada vez y desafortunadamente
las personas electas en una cantidad de
estados como la florida son
conservadores o republicanos aunque
sabemos que el derecho de las armas no
debía ser ni republicano ni democracia
porque al fin y al cabo lo que estamos
teniendo es personas que mueren todos
los días por casa que se puede entrenar
y claro así es con ese panorama maribel
y desde estas iniciativas ciudadanas por
ejemplo como la que usted impulsa
contra quien se está luchando
exactamente aquí luchan es contra los
fabricantes de las armas contra el lobby
que hay en el congreso contra una
legislación que está instaurada y
arraigada también en el sentir de la
sociedad estadounidense o contra esos
intereses particulares que hay en el
mercado ilegal que ya vamos a hablar de
ese tema el mercado ilegal de armas que
hay en eeuu o simplemente contra la
legislatura de turno
para la florida de la legislatura de
turno definitivamente pero llevamos 20
años 20 años con esta mayoría por lo
tanto es muy difícil hacer cambios que
no sean ellos no estén de acuerdo con
ellos pero sí existen iniciativas por
ejemplo los jóvenes they de parkland que
han conformado una organización hacen un
lobby muy bueno a través de todo el país
lo hacen en washington lo hace en la
florida pero la asociación nacional del
rifle es muy fuerte es una sesión muy
fuerte que como vimos fueron lo que
representaron a los dos individuos en
nueva york que llegaron hasta la corte
de prueba para hacer cambiar esta ley
del mayor o sea que tenemos una
legislación que tiene un concepto de la
segunda enmienda muy arraigado y muy
primitivo en muchos muchos casos y
tenemos una asociación nacional del
rifle que es muy muy poderosa que
controla mucho las decisiones de los
legisladores y ya tenemos con unos
votantes que tratan todo lo más que
pueden pero solamente llegamos a cierto
punto cada año si su opinión mariaelena
sobre este tema sobre contra quien se
está luchando en realidad esto es los
fabricantes el lobby la legislación de
turno
el gobierno de turno o ese mercado
ilegal
mira yo creo que se está luchando contra
los intereses económicos por supuesto de
los de la asociación nacional del rifle
pero también los temas económicos con
respecto a los grupos de crimen
organizado porque el crimen organizado
no es como era hace décadas donde eran
unos hampones que éste que simplemente
comerciaban drogas y armas hoy estamos
viendo que esos hampones ya están en las
oficinas de nueva york o de la ciudad de
mexico de cualquier ciudad grande que se
visten bien y que lavan dinero no y que
este dinero bueno pues sirve para este
temas económicos en todas partes
entonces sí me parece que tenemos que
repensar nuestras políticas en contra de
la violencia porque estamos actuando
como si estuviéramos en los países que
como estaban en 1920 no nada más que
estamos en 2020 en mil en 2022 no
entonces no podemos seguir pensando que
ese tipo de legislación sirva para la
situación tan violenta que estamos y
muchas raíces en el mundo no y que pues
que al final de cuentas yo diría
santiago todo se termina moviendo por el
dinero de repensar políticas eso implica
entender que estamos en una coyuntura
muy distinta y que además las armas que
se usaban en 1920 cuando estas leyes
fueron aprobadas son muy distintas al
amo a las modernas armas que se están
desarrollando hoy en día no sólo en eeuu
sino también en otros países del mundo
maría elena entonces desde ese punto de
vista una solución para poder mitigar un
poco la violencia en eeuu podría ser
legislación desde el parlamento desde el
congreso de eeuu pero hacia los
fabricantes restringir la fabricación
reducir la fabricación bueno yo creo que
ese es uno es uno de los temas que ha
estado en la mesa durante mucho tiempo
el restringirles la fabricación
precisamente de armas porque no pueden o
sea yo sí creo que la gente pueda tener
derechos a tener sorbe en su casa y su
arma si se va a ir a cazar como te decía
patos pero de ahí a usar armas a poder
comprar armas de asalto sin ninguna
restricción cuando precisamente saben
que desde que se cambió la legislación
en eeuu en el 2004
hay muchísimo más venta de arma ilegal
hacia méxico que lo que había antes
entonces de hecho tanto los legisladores
como los políticos y como la gente en
eeuu sabe que la venta de armas de
asalto no es un tema que sea porque la
gente necesita tener eso en su casa ni
salir a la calle con esto si no es un
tema completamente económico y de cerrar
los ojos y admitir que todo pase no
porque hay huecos en la ley en eeuu como
en todas partes del mundo y estos huecos
de la ley pues los utiliza esta gente y
al final del día recordemos que no no
estamos hablando solamente de armas y de
dinero de lo que principalmente hablando
son de las miles de miles de vidas que
se pierden cada año por esto claro de
familias que están sufriendo porque
alguno de sus miembros fue asesinado
maribel su opinión sobre este tema una
posible restricción a los mismos
fabricantes o dejar como pasan algunos
países que todo el tema armamentístico
que ha reducido a las fuerzas armadas de
ese país y no a la sociedad a los
ciudadanos del común
eso sería muy difícil porque como te
digo
estamos muy arraigados con lo que la
segunda enmienda nos dice nos hace y lo
vimos con esta decisión última acerca de
nueva york donde realmente decidieron
que es mucho más pura la interpretación
que la que le hemos dado anteriormente
también en el problema de los rifles de
asalto no estuvimos prohibidos por un
tiempo aquí y vimos los resultados de
que si hace una diferencia o sea que el
prohibir los rays del asalto es algo muy
importante muy importante para todas las
organizaciones a las cuales yo estoy
asociada y yo creo que definitivamente
salvaría vidas como hemos visto en todos
los incidentes de las escuelas ha sido
utilizado este tipo de rifles que no es
necesario para alguien que no sea es que
va a pelear en la guerra por ejemplo o
sea que esa parte si yo creo en muchas
organizaciones que están de acuerdo en
que se debería definitivamente prohibir
en mi mercado los lógicos los rifle de
asalto problemas complemento lo que dice
en maribel sobre la segunda enmienda de
la constitución de eeuu una propuesta
presentada el 25 de septiembre de
1789 y fue aprobada el 15 de diciembre
de 1791 y esta enmienda protege el
derecho del pueblo estadounidense a
poseer y portar armas en forma parte de
la carta de los derechos estadounidenses
conocida como the bill of rights ahí es
donde está el centro de toda esta
discusión en pleno 2022
no se nos olvida y no se nos escapa un
punto que hemos venido tratando acá y es
y tal vez es uno de estos agujeros que
vuelve y deja esta ley esta modificación
y es la venta de armas entre civiles
porque está muy bien que él
el almacén donde la persona se acerca a
ella quiere cualquier tipo de arma que
desea pues hasta hay un control pero
luego lo que haga esa persona con el
arma ya pues es totalmente privado
porque es un bien privado que tiene esta
persona y puede usarla para lo que
necesite o desee de acuerdo a la ley
pero ese tipo de ventas maribel entre
civiles puede volverse entonces sigue
siendo otro agujero de la ley que sigue
generando problemas y pues vuelve a
generar complicaciones para para evitar
este tipo de tiroteos
bueno santiago en cuanto a esa parte si
la ley que estaba formulada por lo menos
vas a hacer algo para remediar eso qué
es lo que tiene que ver por ejemplo
cuando hay que hemos visto en las
imágenes que estaba pasando donde son
los se llaman los shows donde las
personas van a comprar armas en una
feria y en este tipo de
evento se ha podido comprar las armas
sin tener ningún tipo de chequeo de
antecedentes y no hay una buena
regulación acerca de los en las personas
que venden en este tipo de eventos en la
ley que esté qué pasó si se va a ocupar
de poner algún tipo de restricción a
actualizar un poco el lenguaje en torno
a los vendedores de armas con licencias
de ocio que tienen que tener una
licencia para poder vender y una vez que
tú vas tienes ese tipo de requerimiento
tienes que exigir todo lo que la ley
exige como sería los antecedentes de la
espera de algunos lugares tienes que
parar 24 horas antes que la pueda
recoger el arma por lo tanto eso sí es
algo bueno que sucedió en lo que
promulgó el congreso en cuanto a regular
un poco más esto y la laguna bien grande
en cuanto a las personas que trafican
con armas sin tener que tener ningún
tipo de regulación
maría elena en ciudad de méxico aquí
estamos hablando de libertad es esto
está en la constitución de eeuu en qué
punto se llega o se sobrepasa esa raya
de libertades de garantías para los
ciudadanos y el bien común aquí se está
viendo afectado el bien común con estos
tipos de tiroteos
la violencia se incrementa y no lo
podemos ver desde el individuo y su
libertad sino en el bien de la sociedad
estadounidense
noda esto para pensar para repensar esos
derechos esas libertades de los
estadounidenses
mira yo creo que los derechos tienen que
ir acompañados de responsabilidades y me
parece que los estadounidenses no se han
hechos responsables de lo que está
sucediendo en su propio país como tú
bien decías pues es una ley que estaba
en mil que se que se aprobó en
1791 cuando
seguramente y no seguramente a fuerzas
pues toda la gente que vivía en eeuu
casi todas vivían en comunidades
pequeñas y alejadas muy alejadas de uno
u otro lugar no y entonces pues era era
importante tener una ley así sin embargo
hoy en día la gran mayoría de los
estadounidenses viven en ciudades
constituidas bien bien arma bien esté
bien constituidas puestas donde tienen
una infinidad de posibilidades en lugar
de tener que usar un arma en la calle no
entonces sí creo que lo que pasa es que
no nos hemos no se ha puesto a pensar
estas personas de la asociación nacional
del rifle al igual que los legisladores
en eeuu la gravedad por la que está
pasando el problema de violencia en eeuu
y en el mundo donde además hay mucho más
personas que no están bien de la cabeza
y que son capaces de salir a matar pues
como lo hemos visto en estos últimos
años claro en las masacres que se han
dado en eeuu entonces ellos sí creo que
se debería pues todos deberíamos de
avanzar en la reflexión
de si lo que queremos es solamente
derechos o derechos con
responsabilidades maría elena continuó
con los tremendas restablecemos la
conexión con maribel en la ciudad de
miami y le preguntó por un punto que
usted menciona la salud mental también
es momento de cuestionar cómo está la
salud mental de los ciudadanos
estadounidenses sobre todo ahora que
estamos saliendo de este escenario de
pandemia después de haber salido de
meses de confinamiento se están haciendo
estudios al alrededor de este tema se ha
mirado ya desde otra perspectiva la
salud mental de esta sociedad
y continuar utilizando armas de fuego
amparados bajo la ley
fíjate que no sé de ningún estudio
terminado que esté sin embargo
seguramente si se estaban haciendo
estudios al respecto porque el tema del
confinamiento también nos llevó a tener
un problema
pues de estrés gravísimo mental no donde
mucha gente también perdió muchos bienes
muchos perdieron su trabajo la gente
estaba enclaustrada en su casa y esto ha
tenido cambios de comportamiento
importante en siempre que hay un tema de
estrés grande en una sociedad o en una
familia o en una persona bueno pues
precisamente por eso le llama el estrés
postraumático no y este tema de salud no
se está atendiendo por ejemplo nosotros
lo vemos en méxico no es un tema que se
esté atendiendo y traemos nosotros el
problema del gobi pero a ese problema
hay que aumentarle el problema de
violencia intrafamiliar la el problema
de las violencias que se viven en méxico
entonces sí es un punto muy importante
el tener una estrategia especial con sus
recursos para tratar los problemas
mentales de la gente porque por el
comportamiento que tiene mucha gente
pues me parece que es el sentido de
manera algo grave lo está pasando como
sociedad
bueno pues ya me quedan pocos minutos
pocos segundos para finalizar el
programa le agradezco a maría elena
morera y a maribel balbín que se conecta
a justo para el cierre le agradezco
muchísimo haber estado con nosotros y
haber puesto sobre la mesa sus opiniones
y su análisis sobre este tema sobre esta
ley promulgada y en eeuu ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y todas
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales de france 24 y por supuesto
pueden seguir con nuestra programación
sigan con nosotros
[Música]